allez-vous foule une rencontre très
optimiste c'est ainsi que goodluck
johnatan médiateur attitré de la cedeao
résume ses discussions avec les
militaires désormais au pouvoir au mali
la délégation de la communauté des états
de l'afrique de l'ouest mené par
l'ancien président nigérian a été reçu
par les membres du comité national pour
le salut du peuple qui a renversé le
président ibrahim boubacar kéïta mardi
dernier les discussions qui se
poursuivent ce week-end vise un accord
d'ici à lundi
nous avons compris que des chefs d'état
comme l'ivoirien alassane ouattara
travaille pour une décrispation pour une
solution pacifique même s'ils ont
fermement condamné notre prise de
pouvoir nous sommes ouverts aux
discussions
goodluck johnatan a été mandaté par la
cedeao pour assurer un retour immédiat
de l'ordre constitutionnel au mali
l'organisation intergouvernementale
dénonce coup d'état militaire mais face
au soutien populaire et à la bénédiction
du mouvement d'opposition malien m 5
la cedeao souhaite trouver un compromis
la cedeao a essentiellement pour rôle
d'accompagner le mali la solution que
nous devons trouver et je crois que tout
le monde est d'accord c'est une solution
qui satisfasse les maliens d'abord et
qui sont aussi bénéfiques pour tous les
pays de la sous région
la délégation de la cedeao s'est aussi
rendu à cathy dans la banlieue de bamako
devenue le fief des militaires au
pouvoir les envoyer ouest africains ont
pu y rencontrer le président déchu
ibrahim boubacar keita ainsi que
d'autres personnalités arrêtées par les
militaires après tous ses contacts
la cedeao a précisé ses objectifs
associer l'ensemble de la classe
politique malienne à la sortie de crise
et veiller au respect des droits de
l'homme dans le pays